this is Startalk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here look who I found wandering the
streets of New Jersey yeah haha senator
Cory Booker it's always delight to be
with you I haven't you have no idea that
it's my delight actually no no no no
this uh this you're such a beautiful
admiration cap the reality is you are
like heroic to me and I just want to
thank you so this your second time on I
am I am I you know they're many to
timers you cross the moat the the the
Hudson River to join us it up at the
Apollo Theater last time yes and now
we're in The Count Basie Theatre in New
Year's a jersey yes yes I trust the moat
back we have a gravitational force to do
it okay this was not a black hole did
you know New Jersey is the most densely
populated state yes I've known ever
since I was a kid I memorized data like
that for safe yes yes yes I would say
everybody wants to be here well so I
asked how could it be the most densely
populated state and be called the Garden
State there's something not working
about that bill are like the fourth
largest producer of cranberries in the
country cranberry you just lied about we
actually already funded blueberries
cranberries we have wonderful gifts that
we give but I've never accidentally
wandered into a cranberry patch you know
but you should feel at home here because
this is one of our greatest states when
it comes to science and innovation that
is true I'm everything with
biotechnology in fact you have the
highest the density of PhDs per capita
the country yes because you've got
Princeton and Rutgers and all but the
pharma yeah here yeah and and
Educational Testing Service and higher
absolutely and if you go back and go
smartass state we do it and I mean
Thomas Edison's biggest inventing Gary
was here yeah the effect is a city
called Edison yes indeed I mean
everything from the submarine to one of
the greatest inventors Newark New Jersey
Seth Boyden who invented everything from
malleable iron which was the first time
you can sort of bend and shave iron I
didn't know that and patent leather
really yes and in fact when we would we
be without patent I just want you to
know that see toes were just looked so
bad from the knees down exactly um and
and of course this is the state that
invented the mm I did not know that
yes so which is the ones is it the
green ones or the blue ones felt I think
what the Red Dog the real know the ones
that are an aphrodisiac oh one green
kebab we had in nose why is it that you
took mmm there and you didn't take
patent leather I don't understand
I heard it's just a mad one day will you
dedicate your brain no no no no no
so how where are you in your six-year
term right now I am right smack in the
middle because I was elected in 2013 to
finish off the term of the late great
frank Lautenberg oh I forgot about yeah
so then I was lucky for a full term in
2014 and have to run again in 2020 okay
so get my time yeah I'm in the Midway
yeah yeah because I represent how some
representatives with only a two-year
term they're like campaign it all alone
as always it's unfortunate yes
unfortunate but you get it means you can
actually get some work done
yeah yeah but I do think there are some
visits there's a genius to our system
but I do now see that the other
countries have a benefit like China can
look forward 25 years but we're often
making eyes i watch on the somatization
yeah and the bowels of the senate people
are making very short-term like how does
it's going to affect me because i got an
election coming up it's sometimes
unfortunately I think away some people
might think so maybe we need super
members of Congress who their 20 year
terms they could put in for the long
term so friggin Oh Matt ER is because if
I find an asteroid that's going to come
don't tell me I can't allocate that
because I'm not going to be in office
when they don't know I think I'm shocked
to be alive after it hit I think climate
change is a great example of that it's
unequivocally something catastrophic
who's going to happen unless we take
dramatic action happen to our
descendants yes my descendants but we're
failing to do that because again people
don't only looking at the immediate in
the short term right the way that all
and a system doesn't allow the long term
view right right okay and there's no
rewards for I literally had a mock to
tell you the politician but I've been
spending years working on the tunnels
between New York and New Jersey yes
underneath the Hudson River yes my first
came in nothing was happening I said
we've got to get this going with a
summit meeting my office with the
cabinet secretary the governor and so
forth but one of the famous quotes that
was being talked about with somebody
said hey if I do this on my watch it
won't be until my successor successor
that they get to cut the ribbon on there
and they get the credit and they'll get
the credit yeah and so that's
unfortunate
it's an unfortunate reality I mean you
understand that sentiment and we wish
the system didn't have to promote that
sentiment yeah but also I wish first of
all there's a statesmanship there's a
patriotism when you look at generations
yet to come when you plant trees under
which whose shade and quiet that whole
it is good example we need to be aware
what's a tree well I live in Manhattan
we do it I heard there's a tree that
grows in Brooklyn but other than that
I'm sitting with a number one cherry
blossoms in America I'm fitting in all
this New Jersey trivia mister Jersey its
Newark more Jersey's not in DC no more
Cherry Bomb Lion I am not lying cut
don't cut there make sure this part did
in Newark New Jersey most hairy vlog
really you should come with just missing
eye judgment right now yeah we peed a
little bit after Washington DC as you
might expect as were farther north yeah
yes yeah the drive-in movie theater
rented in New Jersey
really first am/fm this man did his New
Jersey homework train that connected
this country when the Transcontinental
road built in Paterson New Jersey
really so Cory we're about to go do a
show here at the theater so yeah thanks
for coming in for this thank you for
your podcast
oh yeah just entertaining informative
but it's also kind of inspiring and
enjoyable
so I appreciate thank you that means a
lot to me because we try to make that
what the podcast is yeah and it's not
always that what you intend is what is
received yes and if you receive what we
intended means we're hitting the toners
yes so that's good so I'm going to
confirm with you a like last time we had
a pre-show conversation we discussed I
don't know if you run there's all kinds
of deep philosophical stuff in physics
yeah we talked about astrophysics yeah
we confirmed the fact that the stars
even they're dead we still see them as
if they're there and the stuff some of
them are still sending their light to us
you know there's a movie that came out
last year called la correspond ends and
it starts Jeremy Irons it's an Italian
movie and in it he's an astral he plays
an astrophysicist that's why I noticed
and he has a terminal disease and his
girlfriend is love interest does not
know this he goes away and he dies but
he preloaded correspondence that she
kept receiving thinking he was alive
and this is exactly like a star that has
just exploded and you don't know it the
signal keeps coming but I think that
that's like people like I was literally
driving in the car and I confess listen
to one of my favorite artists Prince
he's long gone but the energy that he
created while I was here still living
goes and fills the air it's like the
first rule this is me doing little geek
research I'm trying to get some heat
credit here the first rule of whistle
check it was still verifying that
perfect rule thermodynamics which is you
don't talk about there or that no it's a
flight club reference for those of you
don't know um know is about the law of
conservation of energy right and and so
I energy created can't be dissipated
right right well it'll become other
forms and it's there somewhere right and
in this case what you do is because he
laid song to track you can resurrect
that energy on command yes and have them
then but isn't it true though that if I
live a life where I generate kindness
and love and warmth even when I'm dead
since that the wall thermodynamics that
can't be destroyed it goes on well okay
I'm not I'm not going to no I'm going to
land that plane at some blind little
town out of the challenge I land the
plane let me give you the example of it
okay good my ultimate love transcends
dimensions I am going to I'm going to
the theme of the movie interstellar by
the way right all the laws of physics
were contained in their dimension but
love transmitted through time okay and
I'm going to show you I'm going to
demonstrate to you I'm about to take on
a physicist here with love and when
watch this okay so take my father mm-hmm
born in 1936 in core to a single mother
in a segregated environment go and I
practice history back to slavery poverty
from slavery to where he was and then
his life changed why his mama couldn't
take care of his grandmama couldn't take
care of him people took him into their
home and when he and and helped raise
him when he couldn't afford to go to
college people told him you're going to
go to college they took a church
collection plate and and and and and and
they talk about karma here they're
talking about what's the ROI the return
on investment those people that put
those dollar bills and their acts of
kindness actually span the past forward
fast forward and affected generations
yet unborn I would not be here those
people are long dead
but I would not be here I'm still
benefiting from that light and that
warmth as this a distant star which has
died out it's still affecting
generations yet unborn warmth and light
so so I'll give you one last example
you know John Lewis yes amazing human
being yes so one little rights activist
yes my mom my dad died six days before I
was elected to the Senate so I mom took
me to go see him and it was amazing and
just right before I was sworn in which
was just and he's so humble I mean he
was wouldn't let me get up he's serving
me food I mean it's just he just kept
telling me how important I was a fourth
elected african-american in the history
of our country to the Senate and he just
told me what it meant to him and I'm
sitting there oh my god it's because of
you and others who fought these battles
now years later I was in all those
marches at all Martin Luther King and he
was there and when you go into his
office that the pictures of him on the
pictures these math amazing moments in
civil rights history that you know march
on Washington march over the Edmund
Pettis bridge but the KZ thing is when
your office you see wait you're there
you're there you're in the pictures like
having museum in your house but you're
in famous moments right so fast-forward
to me writing a book I had to go back
and research a book that I was writing
about my early why I wrote I did called
United right and the title will title
until this airline incident oh yeah oh
but um called Delta yes but one of the
stories in the book I had the research
was these lawyers that helped my family
move in in 1969 to it once before a
segregated environment in New Jersey so
in 1969 all-white town my family tries
to move in can't move in real estate
agents keep telling them lies like oh
that house is sold they set up a sting
operation white couple follows my
parents after they're told the house is
sold they'll go and find out the houses
for sale the house my parents loved that
lawyer set up the sting operation
lawyers living on the day of the closing
when the white couple on their clothes
walk them out swap them out but the real
estate that's a sting that that real
estate agent stands up punches my dad's
lawyer takes a dog on my dad it was such
a fantastic story I had to fact-check it
and so I go back to find one of the
lawyers involved and I said to him
why would you do this he was a young
lawyer just starting his practice not
making much money at all but he took all
this time to help black families moving
into New Jersey asked why and he goes
well I know the day and I go how do you
know the day he goes it was a Monday and
I go how do you know it was a Monday he
goes because that's Sunday I was sitting
at home watching my TV and I saw these
people trying to march across a bridge
and they got beaten with billy clubs and
tear gas and I was so moved at first I
told my partner let's go to Alabama and
helping they said we can't afford that
so they decided to do the best they
could with what they had where they were
where they were and and with one of the
first or early files that they got was
my parents file and so think about this
an action now you know leaping time and
space and action it's a thread of causes
and effect thread of causes in effect
from marches on a bridge instantly
changing the perspective of a New Jersey
lawyer who then goes on to affect
generations yet unborn I would not be a
senator today if that causal reaction of
love sparked on a bridge sparked a
lawyer sparked an activist Here I am
okay I can I concede you in this case
wait a moment wait wait a minute only oh
my god love transcends the boundaries of
the space-time continuum this is what my
greatest like mobile okay we guys we
gotta get ready to go okay
thanks dude I'm a huggy all right all
right I think we out hey did you like
that cool video huh well how about a
bunch of cool videos all commercial free
plus exclusive original content that you
can't find anyplace else all on Startalk
all-access calm